ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRO.
BURKE CALDERON CARILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DE.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINAGARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK
SILVA. RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT AND WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PETTY
STUFF PREVENTION. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A MOMENT OF REFLECTION.
LAST JUNE I SHARED INSIGHTS
FROM AN ARTICLE ENTITLED ALL I
REALLY NEED TO KNOW. ABOUT HOW
TO LIVE LIFE I LEARNED IN
KINDERGARTEN. THE ARTICLE
LISTED LESSONS OF KINDNESS AND
COMMON SENSE THAT WE ALL
LEARNED AS CHILDREN. THINGS
LIKE PLAY FAIR. DON'T TAKE
THINGS THAT AREN'T YOURS SAY
YOU'RE SORRY WHEN YOU HURT
SOMEBODY. ON THIS DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE WE ARE REMEMBERING
A TIME WHEN THESE COMMONSENSE
RULES OF COURTESY THAT WE ALL
KNEW AS CHILDREN WERE
DISREGARDED. WHEN FAIR FAIR
PLAY WAS FORGOTTEN AND THINGS
WERE TAKEN THEY CAN NEVER BE
REPLACED. IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES THE LATE FRED
KOREMATSU SAID. I STILL
REMEMBER. FORTY YEARS AGO. WHEN
I WAS SHACKLED INPUT INTO
PRISON. BEING AMERICAN CITIZEN
DIDN'T MEAN A THING. BUT ONE
PERSON CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE
EVEN IF IT TAKES FORTY YEARS.
EVEN AFTER ALMOST EIGHTY YEARS
IN APOLOGIZING FOR WHAT WE DID
WRONG. WE KNOW AGAIN THAT WE
MUST LIVE FIND OUR BEST TO
ALWAYS DO THE RIGHT THING. NOW
MORE MENDOZA WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS. THANK
YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AS HE LEADSUS IN
THE PLEDGE MYSTERY. READY
SALUTE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE. AND. THIS IS A LITTLE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY THE
ASSEMBLY MET AT SEVEN AM ON
WILL STEVEN S. CHOI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SIXTY EIGHT DISTRICT
PRESIDING SIXTY PARKER AT THE
DESK BEING QUIRK ASHLEY AND
LOUIS READING MR CALL ON MOVES.
WALDRON SECONDS THAT READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATION
EMITATIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. MANY
CALL MOM. O'DONNELL VINCE FONG
AND JIM PATTERSON FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS KEN COOLEY AND
BILL QUIRK AND FOR MATERNITY
LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES.
MEMBERS WE ARE
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED HER
PROCEDURE MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SHOWS. I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW SOMETHING MEMBERS
GALLAGHER IS ERIN AND WEBER TO
SPEAK ON IN GERMANY MEMORY
TODAY. AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK
FOR YOUR GAS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES WE ALL KNOW HOW NICE
IT IS A TO SEE FRIENDLY FACES
FROM BACK HOME COME AND VISIT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO SO IT'S MY
PLEASURE. TO INTRODUCE SOME
FOLKS FROM THE PALO ALTO CITY
COUNCIL AND CITY STAFF WE HAVE
ERIC FILL SETH- WHO WAS THE
MAYOR LAST YEAR. THE TABLE OUT
TO YOU SERVING ME ON THE CITY
COUNCIL. ALISON CORMAC WHO WAS
ELECTED TO THE CITY COUNCIL
LAST YEAR IN A STARTING OUR
SECOND YEAR AND CICADA THE CITY
MANAGER FROM PALO ALTO.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE GIVE THEM A
WARM WELCOME TO SACRAMENTO.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE. ON
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS ONE TWO
AND THREE ARE TO BE CONTINUED.
WE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. H. R. SEVENTY
SEVEN. MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOR HR SEVENTY SEVEN BY
MISTER MURATSUCHI THE CLERK
READ HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO WALDRON TO JAPANESE AMERICAN
CONCENTRATION CAMPS MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TO PRESENT
HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY SEVEN.
AN APOLOGY FROM OUR HOUSE TO
ALL AMERICANS OF JAPANESE
ANCESTRY FOR THE PAST LESS THAN
OF ACTIONS OF THIS LEGISLATURE
IN SUPPORT OF THE ON JUST
INCLUDE EXCLUSION REMOVAL AND
INCARCERATION OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS DURING WORLD WAR TWO.
YES THEY MARK THE SEVENTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF PRESIDENT
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER. NINE OH SIX SIX WHICH
LED TO THE MASS INCARCERATION
OF OVER ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND JAPANESE AMERICANS
WITHOUT DUE PROCESS OF LAW. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT PRESIDENT
RONALD REAGAN SIGNED THE CIVIL
LIBERTIES ACT WHICH IS ISSUED
AN APOLOGY ON BEHALF OF THE
NATION. FOR THIS GRAVE
INJUSTICE. SO STARK ACT OF
CONGRESS FOUND THAT THE MASS
INCARCERATION OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS WAS NOT JUSTIFIED BY
MILITARY NECESSITY. BUT INSTEAD
WAS CAUSED BY QUOTE RACE
PREJUDICE WARTIME HYSTERIA AND
A FAILURE OF POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP. AND SO YOU MAY ASK
WHY IS THIS RESOLUTION
NECESSARY. THIS HOUSE NEEDS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT'S PAST MISTAKES
AND LEARN THE LESSONS OF
HISTORY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
NOT ALLOW HISTORY TO REPEAT
ITSELF. DURING THE YEARS
LEADING UP TO WORLD WAR TWO.
CALIFORNIA LED THE NATION AND
FANNING THE FLAMES OF RACISM
AND IMMIGRANTS SCAPEGOATING
AGAINST JAPANESE AMERICANS. OUR
HOUSE OUR LEGISLATURE IN THIS
CHAMBER PASSED DISCRIMINATORY
LAWS LIKE THE ALIEN LAND LAW
ACT OF NINETEEN THIRTEEN WHICH
PROHIBITED JAPANESE EMIGRANTS
FROM OWNING HOMES OR FARMS. WE
ALSO PASSED SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTEEN WHICH AFTER
PEARL HARBOR CALLED FOR THE
FIRING OF ALL JAPANESE AMERICAN
STATE EMPLOYEES BECAUSE THEY
WERE FEARED TO BE SPIES. WE
NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THIS
INSTITUTIONS PAST MISTAKES IN
ORDER TO LEARN FROM THEM.
FURTHERMORE THIS RESOLUTION IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE WE SEE WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTRY
TODAY. MIGRANT CHILDREN FROM
MEXICO AND CENTRAL AMERICA
BEING HELD INDEFINITELY IN A
FOR MORE WAR WAR TO JAPANESE
AMERICAN CAMP AT FORT SILL
OKLAHOMA. MUSLIM IMMIGRANTS
BEING PROFILED AND TARGETED
WITH SWEEPING TRAVEL BANS.
CLEARLY WE STILL HAVE MUCH TO
LEARN FROM THE LESSONS OF
HISTORY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
NOT ALLOW HISTORY TO REPEAT
ITSELF. LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT
LEAST THIS APOLOGY IS LONG
OVERDUE. MOST JAPANESE
AMERICANS WHO WERE IN CAMPS
HAVE ALREADY PASSED AWAY. BUT
THIS APOLOGY IS IMPORTANT TOO
MANY CAMP SURVIVORS STILL ALIVE
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE HERE
WITH US TODAY. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR HOUSE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI MISTER VOEPEL YOUR
RECOGNIZE. MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR SEVENTY SEVEN. AND THERE'S A
DIFFERENT TAKE HERE WITH
ANOTHER GROUP FROM THE INTERNET
CAMPS. YOUNG SECOND GENERATION
JAPANESE CALLED KNEES SAY. THEY
FORMED THE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY SECOND REGIMENTAL COMBAT
TEAM WHICH BECAME ONE OF THE
MOST DECORATED UNITS OF THEIR
SIZE IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES ARMY. THEY NOT
ONLY FOUGHT THE GERMANS AND THE
ITALIANS THEY FOUGHT RACISM.
HEAVY DUTY RACISM RIGHT AFTER
PEARL HARBOR THE HAWAIIAN
JAPANESE FORMED AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED THE VARSITY VICTORY
VOLUNTEERS TO HELP DIG TRENCHES
BUNKERS WHATEVER THEY COULD DO
FOR THE DEFENSE OF HAWAII AND
OF COURSE AFTER THEY WEREN'T
NEEDED ANYMORE THEY WERE
DISBANDED. DIDN'T BOTHER THEM.
IN NINETEEN FORTY THREE
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT FORMED THE
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY SECOND
REGIMENTAL COMBAT TEAM IT WAS
COMPRISED OF TWO THIRDS
HAWAIIAN JAPANESE NO THIRD
MAINLAND JAPANESE NOW WHEN THEY
WERE FORMED. THEY DIDN'T GET
ALONG IT WAS WEIRD. MAINLAND
JAPANESE NAMED THE HAWAIIAN
JAPANESE BUDDHA HEADS. THE
BUDDHA HEADS NAMED THE MAINLAND
JAPANESE COULD PUNKS BECAUSE
THAT'S THE SOUND THEIR EMPTY
HEADS MADE WHEN THEY HIT THE
BAR ROOM FLOOR DURING FIGHTS SO
IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT. THE UNIT
WAS CONSIDERED TO BE DISBANDED
IF THEY COULDN'T GET IT
TOGETHER. WELL THE STAFF MEMBER
HAD THE GOOD IDEA OF SENDING
THE COULD PUNKS TO AN
INTERMETALLIC IN ARKANSAS. WHEN
THE BUDDHA'S HEADS WENT WITH
THEM. NOW THE WHOLE UNITS ALL
WHERE THE COULD PUNKS CAME FROM
THEY BECAME OF FIGHTING MACHINE.
MANY BATTLES WERE FOUGHT
AGAINST THE GERMANS AND
ITALIANS IN ONE OF THE BATTLES
AFTER THE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY SECONDED SPENT TEN DAYS
IN HEAVY COMBAT WITH HEAVY
LOSSES. ONE OF THE BATTALIONS
FROM TEXAS WAS SURROUNDED AND
WAS IN DANGER OF BEING WIPED
OUT. THE FOUR FORTY THAT CAN
SAVE THEM AND THIS WAS THE SAME
BATTALION THAT A GIVEN- A
HORRIBLE RACIST. GRIEF BUT THEY
WERE ALMOST DESTROYED SAVING
THIS BATTALION THAT'S THE
COURAGE OF THE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY SECOND. FOUR THOUSAND
WE'RE IN THE UNIT OVER EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND ROTATED THROUGH. THEIR
MOTTO WAS GO FOR BROKE
EVERYTHING A ONE DICE ROLL THAT
WAS THE SPIRIT. OUT OF EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND IT SERVED NINE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX RECEIVE PURPLE HEART SETS
50% TWENTY ONE MEDALS OF HONOR
THE MOST MEDALS OF HONOR IN ANY
ORGANIZATION. OF THAT SIZE THEY
HAD SEVEN PRESIDENTIAL
CITATIONS. THESE PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD OF. HAD A GREAT GREAT
GRUDGE AGAINST THEIR COUNTRY
SERVE THEIR COUNTRY. AND FOUGHT
AND DIED IN LARGE NUMBERS AND
DID IT OUT OF PATRIOTISM AND
FOR TRUTH JUSTICE AND LIBERTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER VOEPEL MS RUBIO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR
SEVENTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINOCAUCUS NEARLY THREE
QUARTERS OF THE JAPANESE
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN FORTY ONE MOVED FROM
THEIR HOMES AND SENT TO CAMPS
IN ARKANSAS AND THE WESTERN
STATES. THEY WERE COMPLETELY
UPROOTED AND FORCED TO LEAVE
THEIR HOMES JOBS AND THEIR
PROPERTY SEES. THIS DARK ERA OF
OUR NATION'S HISTORY WAS
RIDDLED WITH RACIAL PREJUDICE
AND FAILURE OF POLITICAL IT OF
LEADERSHIP. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT JUSTIFIED IN TURNING
JAPANESE AMERICANS IN THE NAME
OF NATIONAL SECURITY. THIS
POLICY WAS CRUEL AND SHORT
SIGHTED. RECENT NATIONAL
POLICIES SPREAD FEAR IN OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES EXCLUDE
SPECIFIC RELIGIONS AND
ETHNICITIES FROM ENTERING THE
U. S. AND PUT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN CAGES DETENTION
CENTERS. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE LOOK TO OUR PAST AND LEARN
FROM OUR MISTAKES CALIFORNIA
MUST LEAD IN THIS ENDEAVOR AND
SHOW THE REST OF THE NATION
THAT WE WILL NOT STAND FOR
RACIST AND PARANOID POLICIES
THAT TAKE AWAY BASIC RIGHTS.
FROM ANY PERSON. IT IS FOR
THESE REASONS THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO MISS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS MORNING I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF BOTH
THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS
IN THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS HR SEVENTY SEVEN SHEDS
LIGHT ON A DARK CHAPTER
CALIFORNIA HISTORY. THE BUT
THIS RESOLUTION GOES BEYOND THE
INJUSTICE OF EXECUTIVE ORDER
NINE. NINETY SIXTY SIX UNDER
WHICH A HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
AMERICANS AND RESIDENTS OF
JAPANESE DESCENT WERE
INCARCERATED IN CONCENTRATION
CAMPS. THIS RESOLUTION ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGES THE ROLE THAT OUR
PREDECESSORS IN THIS VERY BODY
HAD IN SHAPING DECADES WORTH OF
DISCRIMINATORY AND UNJUST
POLICIES AND VIOLATED THE CIVIL
RIGHTS AND CIVIL LIBERTIES OF
OUR FELLOW CALIFORNIANS. THEY
WERE CALIFORNIANS LIKE MISS SU
YEE ENDO WHO WAS FIRED FROM HER
JOB AT THE DMV IN NINETEEN
FORTY TWO FOLLOWING THE PASSAGE
OF S. C. R. FIFTEEN. WHICH
REQUESTED THAT THE STATE
PERSONAL BOARD DISMISSED STATE
EMPLOYEES WHO MAY BE PROVED TO
BE DISLOYAL TO THE COUNTRY. MS
ENDO COURAGEOUSLY FILED SUIT
AGAINST THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT SHE WAS STILL
REMOVED AND INCOME SERRATED
WHILE HERS HER SUIT WAS
PENDING. IT WASN'T UNTIL
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR THAT SHE
WAS FINALLY RELEASED FROM THE
CONCENTRATION CAMP AFTER THE
GOVERNMENT DETERMINED FOR
LOYALTY TO THE STATE'S.
RESOLUTIONS LIKE A SO M. CANNOT
DO THE DESTRUCTION CAUSED BY
OUR ACTIONS EIGHTY YEARS AGO.
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS WERE
CERTAINLY COMPLICIT IN
DESTROYING THE LIVES OF
THOUSANDS. OF THEIR OWN
CONSTITUENTS DURING WORLD WAR
TWO. HOWEVER WITH THIS FORMAL
APOLOGY WE CAN TAKE A STEP
TOWARDS ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE THAT
TRAMPLED OVER THE CIVIL RIGHTS
OF OUR FELLOW CITIZENS. WITH HR
SEVENTY SEVEN WE CAN ENSURE
THAT FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS LEARN FROM THE
TERRIBLE MISTAKES OF OUR
PREDECESSORS. AND THAT EVERY
DAY WE CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
MORE JUSTIN OR EQUAL CALIFORNIA
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS I URGE AN
AYE VOTE ON HR SEVENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THE STATE TREATMENT
MISSED CALIBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOUR MEMBERS
I ALSO RISE IN SOME OF HR
SEVENTY SEVEN- AS I OFTEN HAVE
IN THE PAST WHEN WE WHEN WE
OMMEMORATE AND WE- REMEMBER
THE ATROCITY THAT WAS JAPANESE
INTERNMENT- MANY OF MY-
CONSTITUENTS. THEIR
GRANDPARENTS- WERE INTERNED IN
PLACES LIKE TULE LAKE ANOTHER
INTERNMENT CAMPS- THROUGHOUT.
THE STATE AND WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT. THESE WERE
AMERICANS OKAY THESE WERE
PEOPLE WHO. EMIGRATED FROM
JAPAN- BUT SETTLED HERE AT
ESTABLISH FARMS HERE AND MANY
OF THEM MULTI GENERATIONAL AND
IT AND IT DOESN'T MATTER
THEY'RE A MULTI GENERATIONAL OR
NOT BUT THEY HAD BECOME. SICK
SINCE. MADE THIS THEIR HOME AND
WE SAID TO AMERICAN CITIZENS.
PROPERTY AWAY FROM AND WE PUT
THEM IN CAMPS WITHOUT ANY DUE
PROCESS OF LAW. WHAT WHAT THIS
COUNTRY DID AND THIS STATE DID
NEEDS TO BE APOLOGIZE FOR A
NEEDS TO BE. RECOGNIZE FOR THE
ATROCITY THAT IT WAS THAT'S NOT
WHO WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE. AS
AMERICANS. AND THE STATE DID
HAVE A KEY ROLE IN THAT.
IRONICALLY IT WAS FRANKLIN
DELANO ROOSEVELT WHO SAID WE
HAVE NOTHING TO FEAR BUT FEAR
ITSELF. AND YET WHEN HYSTERIA
AND FEAR CAME IN ON THIS ISSUE
HE GAVE IN TO IT. AND EARL
WARREN YAHOO IS A ANOTHER KEY
ARCHITECT OF INTERNMENT GAVE
INTO THAT. FEAR AND MANY
POLITICIANS AS HAS BEEN POINTED
OUT GAVE INTO THAT FEAR AND
HYSTERIA. AND ALLOWED THAT FEAR.
TO THEN TURN INTO TAKING AWAY
PEOPLE'S CIVIL RIGHTS. AND
CERTAINLY I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE SHOULD ALWAYS
THINK ABOUT- WE'VE WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT CHINESE EXCLUSION
VERY SIMILAR. YOU KNOW YOU
WOULD THINK THAT- WE WOULD HAVE
LEARNED OUR LESSON BECAUSE ONLY
SIX YEARS BEFORE CHINESE
EXCLUSION HAD AND HYSTERIA HAD
TAKEN OVER AND THOSE- POLICIES
WERE PASSED AND THEN- IN THE
FORTIES JAPANESE INTERNMENT SO
WE DO NEED TO RECOGNIZE WHAT
HAPPENS THIS BODY IN AND IT IS
RELEVANT. TO TODAY- THAT WE
ALLOW FEAR TO GUIDE US. WE
OFTEN DO THINGS THAT UNDERMINE
PEOPLE'S RIGHTS. AND I WOULD
SAY WHEN WE HAVE A RIGHTEOUS
FEAR EVEN WE MIGHT HAVE A
RIGHTEOUS FEAR WE HAVE A RIGHT
HIS FEAR OF GUN VIOLENCE. IN
THIS COUNTRY BUT IF WE LET THAT
FEAR. LEAD US TO UNDERMINING.
CITIZENS LAWFUL AND
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS WHEN LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS. RIGHTS ARE
UNDERMINED OUT OF A FEAR. OF
WHAT COULD HAPPEN WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT THAT. CLIMATE
CHANGE IS A VERY REAL ISSUE
THAT MANY OF THIS BODY WANT TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT. BUT WHEN WE
HAVE A RIGHT WHEN WE HAVE A
FEAR THAT LEADS US TO TAKE AWAY
PEOPLE'S PROPERTY RIGHTS. THAT
LEADS US TO TAKE AWAY PEOPLE'S
RIGHT TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
HOW THEY WANT TO WORK THE CROPS
THAT THEY WANT TO GROW. THE
CARS THAT THEY WANT TO DRIVE.
WHEN WASTE WHEN WE START SAYING
WE HAVE TO TAKE AWAY YOUR
RIGHTS BECAUSE WE ONLY HAVE TEN
YEARS. AND WE USE HYSTERIA TO
DO THINGS TO TAKE AWAY PEOPLE'S
RIGHTS WE SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT THOSE THINGS THERE'S MANY
AND THERE'S MANY EXAMPLES THAT
WE CAN POINT TO. IT'S ALWAYS
RELEVANT FOR US TO REMEMBER.
THAT TIME. WE DO HAVE NOTHING
TO FEAR BUT FEAR ITSELF BUT
LET'S ACTUALLY LIVE UP TO THAT
MOTTO WHEN WE'RE MAKING POLICY
LET'S NOT ALLOW FEAR. TO LEAD
US TO UNDERMINING PEOPLE'S
RIGHTS THAT IS A LESSON. I
BELIEVE OF HISTORY AND
HOPEFULLY WILL CONTINUE.
HOPEFULLY WE WILL HAVE LEARNED
THE LESSONS OF HISTORY AND I
THINK IT STARTS BY SUPPORTING
THIS RESOLUTION TODAY
APOLOGIZING FOR THIS ATROCITY.
OF THE PAST OF WHAT WE DID TO
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS. MAY IT
NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN THANK YOU.
DOCTOR WEBER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF H. R. SEVENTY SEVEN.
WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
MISTAKES AND IN AND OF OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT ITSELF TOO OFTEN WE
CHOOSE TO IGNORE INCONVENIENT
TRUTHS. UNTIL IT IS TOO LATE
UNTIL THE PAIN HAS BEEN BORN
TOO LONG ONE TWO A COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN BROKEN AND SCATTERED.
WE OFTEN HAVE THE TENDENCY TO
THINK THAT WERE PART THIS PILOT
THAT WE CAN WASH OUR HANDS OF
THESE MATTERS AND THINGS WILL
BE OKAY. BUT FULLY APOLOGIZE
INTO OUR JAPANESE AMERICANS WHO
SUFFERED THROUGH INTERNMENT
RECOGNIZES AND REQUIRES. AN
ACCURATE ACCOUNTING OF ACTIONS
THAT CALIFORNIA TOOK. TO ENSURE
THE INTERNMENT AND SUBJUGATION
OF JAPANESE AMERICANS. WE
SOMETIMES THINK THAT ORDER
NINETY SIXTY SIX REALLY BEGAN
IN NINETEEN FORTY TWO. BUT THE
REALITY IS IT'S BEEN POINTED UP
OUR MEMBERS. THAT THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF ALIEN LANDECK IN
NINETEEN THIRTY THIRTEEN. WAS
FOR BIDDING OWNERSHIP OF LAND
BY JAPANESE AMERICANS. AND IN
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE THIS VERY
LEGISLATURE ONCE AGAIN ACTED TO
THE COUPLE AMERICAN CITIZENS.
FROM THECIVIL LIBERTIES BY
DIRECTING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
TO VIGOROUSLY PURSUE THESE LAND
LOSS WHILE JAPANESE AMERICANS
WERE INTERNED AND ABLE TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES. THE LAWS
WERE THE RESULT OF RACIAL
ANIMOSITY AND HIS. AND ANYTHING
DO WITH SAFETY AND OF THIS NAY.
WE CAN CONTINUE TO OFTEN DO
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN. BOB
OF REFUSING TO DEAL WITH THE
ISSUES THAT ARE THERE THE
DENIALS THE REFUSALS OF
REFLECTION AND INSIST ON OUR
INFALLIBILITY THAT WE WERE NOT
THERE WOULD NOT RESPONSIBLE IT
WAS OUR GREAT GREAT GRANDFATHER
SO MEMBER WHO DID THIS. AND YET
WITH THAT KIND OF DENIAL AND
DEEP EXAMINATION OF THIS
NATION'S BIGOTRY WE FAIL TO
UNDERSTAND THAT EXTREME
IMPORTANCE OF WHAT WE DO. TO
WALK WE DON'T WANT BE
ACCOUNTABLE AND NOT BEING
APOLOGIZING THE PAIN THAT WE
HAVE BECAUSE OF THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AS A
NATION. BECAUSE WITHOUT DOING
THAT IT SAYS TO THE FUTURE
CHILDREN THAT WHAT TOOK PLACE
WAS BECAUSE THERE WAS A NEED
FOR. THAT IT WAS FOR SAFETY
REASONS OR WHATEVER IT MAY BE
AND YET WE HAVE NOT FULLY
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
RATIONALE FOR WHAT WAS DONE.
OTHER THAN THE SOME BIGOTRY AND
RACISM THAT EXISTED IN THIS
COUNTRY. NO ONE RECOGNIZE THAT
MORE THAN AFRICAN AMERICANS WHO
HAVE PROBABLY BEEN THE MOST THE
RATED IN YOUR THIS NAY. IN
TERMS OF THE LOS THEIR FREEDOM
THEIR LIFE AT TRY TO REACHED.
LIES IN OVER. AND FIND STILL
THE LOS COME IN THAT STRIP
THERE BEING A MEMBER. TO THE
AXE THAT. AND SO IT IS THAT WE
ARE. THAT YOU WILL ALSO
COLLEGES CRITICAL THE POOR.
THAT THEY SOME ANOTHER YOU
EQUAL A WHOLE BECAUSE PEOPLE
HAVE TO NOT THAT THEY DE
SOMETHING TO YOU IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO HEAL A WELL AND DIDN'T
REPEAT THOSE OF OFFENSES AND-
YOU KNOW WITHOUT AN APOLOGY IS
I SAID WE CINEMA TO OUT. TO WE
DID JUST OF. AND THEREFORE WHEN
THEY ARE FACED A SIMILAR
SITUATIONS THEY WOULD DO THE
SAME THING AGAIN IT IS A BIG
PERSON WHO SAYS WE WERE WRONG.
WE SHOULD NEVER DONE IT AND WE
HOPE WILL NEVER HAVE TO DO IT
AGAIN. WHEN I GO TO SOUTH
AFRICA IT'S ALWAYS INTERESTING
THE APARTHEID MUSEUM BUT AFTER
YOU SEE ALL THE ATROCITIES THAT
OF THE SADDAM THING MUSEUM TO.
VERY END TRIP YOU. THEM TO THE
IN THERE'S A ROOM. WITH A WHOLE
BUNCH OF ROCK. AND EVERY HAS TO
PICK UP A ROCK IN SPACE VERY
SIMPLE THAT'S SIMPLE STATEMENT
IS NEVER AGAIN. REAL SIMPLE
NEVER AGAIN. A RECOGNITION THAT
THIS SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN
TO ANYONE FOR ANY REASON IN THE
WORLD. AND IT'S AMAZING HOW-
AFTER GOING TO THE MUSEUM MY
STUDENTS ARE OFTEN IN TWO YEARS
BUT THERE'S SO PROBLEM THEY
PICK UP THAT ROCK IN A TOSS IT
IN SAY NEVER AGAIN. WE HAVE TO
GET TO THE POINT WILL WE EVER
NUYS THE ERRORS OF OP STE AND
WE SAY TO EVERYONE NEVER AGAIN.
I MEAN IT. WE ASK FOR YOUR- FOR
HR SEVEN. THANK YOU DOT WEBER
MISS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER. I RISE AS A
JOINT AUTHOR OF THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZING THE
STAIN ON OUR NATION'S HISTORY.
THEREFORE IT IS CRITICAL THAT
WE RECOGNIZE OUR NATION'S
MISTAKES RIGHT THE WRONGS OF
THE PAST AND COMMITTED TO
BUILDING A BETTER MORE JUST
FUTURE. WITH THE STROKE OF A
PEN PATRIOTIC AMERICANS WERE
TORN FROM THEIR HOMES FAMILIES
JOBS AND BUSINESSES AND THEY'RE
VERY WAY OF LIFE. EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO PEOPLE
DIED IN THE CAMPS. THE
HORRIFYING CHAIN OF EVENTS
REPRESENTS ONE OF HISTORY'S
GREAT FAILURES OF LEADERSHIP.
ELLER BY PRESIDENT FRANKLIN
ROOSEVELT WHO ISSUED THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER FAILURE BY
CONGRESS TO INTERVENE FAILURE
BY STATE GOVERNMENTS TO PROTECT
THE RESIDENTS CIVIL RIGHTS AND
SAFETY AND FAILURE BY THE U. UP
IN COURT. IN ITS KOREMATSU
RULING. YEARS LATER PRESIDENT
RONALD REAGAN SIGNED INTO LAW
THE CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH
APOLOGIZE FOR THE INTERNMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE US GOVERNMENT. IN
HIS REMARKS PRESIDENT REAGAN
RECOGNIZE THE PATRIOTISM AND
LOYALTY OF THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN PEOPLE EVEN AFTER
THEIR COUNRY TURNED ITS BACK
ON THEM. SO MEMBERS TODAY WE
ALSO STAND TO APOLOGIZE TO THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
VOW NEVER TO REPEAT THE
MISTAKES OF THE PAST I ORIGIN I.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON MR LOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO FIRST OF ALL
THANK OF THE MEMBER FOR
TORRANCE FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORD- IS CLEARLY
RECOGNIZE THAT REPRESENTATION
MATTERS. THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM SAN JOSE AND BORN IN SAN
JOSE I COME FROM THE CAMP IN
THE LEGACY OF. FORMER
CONGRESSMAN FORMER SECRETARY
TRANSPORTATION. NORMAN MINETA.
FORMER CONGRESSMAN MIKE HONDA.
WHO IS ALSO A MEMBER OF THIS
BODY. MR HONDA WAS A MENTOR OF
MINE AND HE WAS ALSO IN
INTERMENT HIMSELF. AND GROWING
UP IN SAN JOSE I DID NOT LEARN
ABOUT THIS AMERICAN HISTORY.
AND THAT'S WHY REPRESENTATION
MATTERS AND THIS RESOLUTION IS
IMPORTANT AND IT'S GREAT TO SEE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION. WHICH GIVES US SOME
PAUSE TO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATION. THE
IMPORTANCE OF ETHNIC STUDIES I
LEARNED ABOUT THIS. NOT IN HIGH
SCHOOL I LEARNED ABOUT IT WHEN
I TOOK ASIAN AMERICAN STUDIES
AT THE AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TO WHICH THEN FORCED ME THEN TO
SAY WHAT IS MY OBLIGATION AS AN
AMERICAN AND HOW COME I DIDN'T
LEARN ABOUT. AIR CAN MISTREAT
OTHER FOURTH GENERATION
CALIFORNIA. AND SO THIS
RESOLUTION. IS A REMINDER THAT
WE MUST CONTINUE TO HELP
EDUCATE OUR COMMUNITY EDUCATE
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA. ABOUT
THAT WE MUST REAFFIRM OUR
COMMITMENT TO THESE VALUES. AND
TO THE JAPANESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. AN AFFIRMATION THAT
WE MUST CONTINUE THE LEGACY OF
THOSE WHO HAVE COME BEFORE US
AND THAT YOUR WORK WE STAND ON
YOUR SHOULDERS AND SO AGAIN TO
THE MEMBER FROM TORRANCE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. FOR US TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR
COLLECTIVE AMERICAN HISTORY.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE THANK YOU
MEMBERS MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR HR SEVENTY SEVEN
BUT I ALSO WANT TO ASK YOU TO
DO SOMETHING ELSE SOMETHING
PERHAPS MORE DIFFICULT. VOTING
ON THIS APOLOGY SHOULD BE ONE
OF THE EASIEST VOTES THAT WE
TAKE ALL YEAR IT'S CLEARLY THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. AND YET
THERE ARE SOME THINGS ABOUT IT
THAT NEED TO BE MADE ENTIRELY
CLEAR. THE CRITICAL POINT OF
THIS RESOLUTION IS NOT THAT WE
APOLOGIZE FOR NATIONAL POLICIES
AGAINST AMERICAN CITIZENS.
DURING WORLD WAR TWO. WE'RE NOT
APOLOGIZING FOR CULTURAL RACISM
IS FEAR ALMOST EIGHTY YEARS
AGO. AND WE ARE NOT MERELY
APOLOGIZING FOR THE ROLE THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA PLAYED
IN THIS INJUSTICE. AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM GLENDALE POINTED
OUT WE ARE SPECIFICALLY
APOLOGIZING FOR THE WRONGS THAT
WERE COMMITTED ON THIS FLOOR.
THIS FLOOR WHERE I NOW NOW
STAND AND WE'RE ALL OF US ALL
OF ALL OF OUR DESKS ARE NOW NOW
SAID. HR SEVENTY SEVEN IS OUR
RESOLUTION AND WE ARE
APOLOGIZING FOR WHAT WE DID. WE
THE LEGISLATURE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS APOLOGY IS OVERDUE. BUT IS
NOT THE MORE DIFFICUT THING I
ASK OF YOU AND OF MYSELF.
IMPORTANT AS THIS RESOLUTION IS
IT IS STILL JUST A RESOLUTION
IT WILL MEAN NOTHING UNLESS WE
LEARN FROM OUR PAST MISTAKES.
ASK OURSELVES THE HARD QUESTION
THAT WE WISH OUR PREDECESSORS
HAD ASKED THEMSELVES. IN ORDER
THAT OUR SUCCESSORS ARE NOT
LEFT APOLOGIZING FOR WHAT WE DO
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
ACTIONS ON THIS FLOOR. EVERY
DAY. ARE TRUE AND JUST WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE ACTIONS
WE TAKE ON THIS FLOOR ARE NOT
ACTS OF RACISM AGAINST OUR OWN
CITIZENS OR RACISM AGAINST
OTHERS FOR THAT MATTER. WE NEED
TO STAND STRONG FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLES
INNOCENT IT PROVING GO WE
CANNOT STAY FOR IMPRISONING
WITH MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN FOR
THINGS THEY HAVE NOT DONE. THIS
IS NOT JUST ABOUT INCARCERATION
A LONG TIME AGO. THIS IS ABOUT
OUR SYSTEM OF JUSTICE IN THE
PRESENT. THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
WHO SUFFERED BECAUSE OF THE
ASSEMBLY IS ACTIONS IN THE
NINETEEN FORTIES ARE NOW GONE.
THEY CANNOT HEAR THE APOLOGY
THAT WE OWE THEM. THIS STEMS
FROM THE PAST BUT IT MUST GUIDE
OUR ACTIONS IN THE PRESENT AND
FAR INTO THE FUTURE. IF WE ACT
JUSTLY IN THE PRESIDENT. IT
WILL MEAN A BETTER FUTURE FOR
CALIFORNIA I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
ON HR. SEVENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I MISTER MERCER
SHE- YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WANT TO THANK EACH
AND EVERY. MEMBER OF THIS BODY
WHO ROSE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION. I NEVER BEEN
MORE PROUD OF BEING PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY- THAN
A TODAY. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE LEVEL OF. AWARENESS OF THE
HISTORY. REGARDING THIS TRAGIC
CHAPTER IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY.
AND I. HOPE THAT THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY CAN TRULY FOLLOW
OUR LEADERSHIP I WANT TO THANK
GIVE A SPECIAL THANKS TO THE
SPEAKER AND TO THE MINORITY
LEADER. FOR THE BIPARTISAN
LEADERSHIP ON THIS RESOLUTION.
CALIFORNIA LEADS BY EXAMPLE.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK OFF
BRAND WITH THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE.
FOR HIS PERSONAL COMMITMENT TO
RIGHT A WRONG THROUGH HIS WORK
ON THIS RESOLUTION. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND ASK FOR THE FIRST
ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
MISTER MURATSUCHI IS REQUESTING
THAT THE FIRST ROLE WE OPEN FOR
CALL AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
CARPOOL OF IN THE RAW. NUMBERS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS MONEY
SEVENTY SEVEN THIS IS CO
AUTHORS. ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THE
CLERK WELL. CLOSE ROLE THERE
ARE SEVENTY TWO CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED MR MURRAY BUT SHE YOUR
AGAIN RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION. THANK MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER WE HAVE. A GROUP OF
SERVE OF CAMP SURVIVORS. AS
WELL AS THEIR FAMILY WHO HAVE
JOINED US TODAY FOR THIS
HISTORIC RESOLUTION WHAT IS
TODAY. OUR CRISTINA META. IT
WAS IN THE TULE LAKE AND HARD
MIND. MARION WHICH- TO A LAKE.
JENNETTE IN NO WAY TO A LAKE.
MERRY OUT SICK TOMORROW JEROME.
KIYOSATO POSTED. LESS A CHEATER
A WRONG. ALLEN CO WHO A GRAN.
OF FRESH KOREMATSU. AND RAP.
THE GENTLEMEN. IN CARS FORMERLY
INCARCERATED AT HEART MOUNTAIN
THE FORMER MAYOR OF SAN JOSE
THE FORMER CONGRESSMAN AND
FORMER UNITED STATES SECRETARY
TRANSPORTATION NORMAN MINETA
ARE HIS SONS. DAVE AND STUART
MINETA PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER.
MEMBERS. MOVING
BRIEFLY BACK TO GUESS
INTRODUCTIONS MR MCCARTY YOUR
GUESTS HAVE ARRIVED IN THE
GALLERY TODAY. MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WE
STUDENTS HERE TO THE STATE
CAPITOL AND MY PLEASURE TO
WELCOME THE SEVENTH AND EIGHTH
GRADERS FROM SAINT ROBERT'S
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL THESE OUR
STUDENTS AND STUDENT GOVERNMENT
AND- THIS IS A NEIGHBORHOOD
JUST SOUTH OF HERE IN THE
HOLLYWOOD PARK NEIGHBORHOOD
WELCOME TO OUR STATE CAPITOL
YOUR STATE CAPITOL. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE FILE
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
ACR ONE FIFTY FOUR BY MS RIVAS
THE CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
THREE OF US RELATIVE TO
INTRODUCE A GIRL TO ENGINEERING
DAY. MS RIVAS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M EXCITED
TO PRESENT ACR ONE FIFTY FOUR
THAT RECOGNIZES TODAY AS
INTRODUCED A GIRL TO
ENGINEERING DAY. AS A FEMALE
ENGINEER IT'S DISCOURAGING TO
KNOW WOMEN CONTINUE TO BE UNDER
REPRESENTED IN ENGINEERING
NATION WIDE WOMEN ONLY ACCOUNT
FOR ABOUT 13% OF ALL PRACTICING
ENGINEERS AND ABOUT 20% OF
BACHELOR DEGREES IN ENGINEERING
ARE AWARDED TO WOMEN.
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER I HAVE
OFTEN HEARD PEOPLE SAY THAT
YOUNG WOMEN DO NOT PURSER IT DO
NOT PURSUE ENGINEERING CAREERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT INTERESTED
IN STEM. BUT I KNOW THAT'S NOT
TRUE. OF BEFORE JOINING THE
LEGISLATURE I STARTED A NON
PROFIT YEAH I GREW UP WITH THE
MISSION TO SPARK INTEREST IN
TECHNOLOGY AND ENGINEERING
AMONG YOUNG GIRLS FROM MY TIME
LEADING D. I. Y. GIRLS. INTO
GIRLS ARE VERY FIRST STEP WITH
NEED TO THEM. EXPOSURE IN KERR
AND THE TOOL. ARE AM BE. SIX AS
A LEAD. TWIN POWER WOMEN TO PER
SEARCH TO PURSUE A CAREER IN
ENGINEERING PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CELL INTO A GRAY TO ENGINEERING
DAY. THANK YOU MS RIVAS SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR TO BE YES. MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ACR ONE
FIFTY FOUR ACKNOWLEDGES THE
DISPARITY BETWEEN MEN AND WOMEN
IN THE ENGINEERING FIELD BY
RECOGNIZING FEBRUARY TWENTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY AS IN PRODUCE A
GIRL TO ENGINEERING DAY AT THE
STATE CAPITOL. MANY I STAY THIS
IS A- USE SANTA AND PRIOR TO
COMING TO THE LEGISLATURE I
WORKED AS AN ENGINEER AT JOHNS
HOPKINS UNIVERSITY APPLIED
PHYSICS LAB AND TELEDYNE
SYSTEMS. WHEN CHOOSING A CAREER
GIRLS DON'T OFTEN THINK OF
ENTERING A HEAVILY MALE
DOMINATED FIELDS LIKE AND JUST
BRING. IN OUR INCREASINGLY. IN
A LOGICAL WORLD HAVING GIRLS
AND WOMEN AT THE TABLE IS VITAL
FOR MAKING SURE THAT WE BUILD.
OUR SOCIETY MORE DIVERSE
PRODUCTS AND CHANGE THINGS FOR
THE BETTER. ACCORDING TO THE
WORLD CAN FORUM AND TRENDS IT
WILL TAKE TWO HUNDRED EIGHT
YEAR TO REACH. IDEA AT NIGHT
IT'S. THE NO BOB SINCE. ARE A-
IN THESE JOB CAN PER BOTH A EX
LIVING AND A- OP. FOR TO BECOME
INNOVATE. WHO TACKLED
CHALLENGED PROBLEMS THAT ENTITY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF GIRLS
AND ENGINEERING HELP CLOSE THE
GENDER WAGE GAP. IT WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT COMPANIES AND
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE DIVERSITY
IN FOUGHT AND PROBLEM SOLVING.
I'M VERY PROUD TO SAY IN MY
DISTRICT AT CAL ANALYZE. EASING
THE VALUE OF GIRLS AND STEM
WITH THIS RESOLUTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTED
INTO MORE GIRLS TO ENGINEERING.
THANK YOU MS IRWIN. SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION THIS RIVAS YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE VOTE ON
THE ARE BEFORE LAST. WILL BE
OPEN TO CO AUTHORS MS RIVAS IS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CARPOOL UP
IN THE ROLE. IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR ONE FIFTY
FOUR. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. I AM SAYING. THE AYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED AND MISS RIVAS BACK TO
YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION THANK YOU TO ALL
THE YOUNG WOMEN WATCHING I WANT
YOU TO KNOW THAT A CAREER IN
ENGINEERING IS ACHIEVABLE IF
YOU SET YOUR MIND TO. THAT IS
THE FOR A FEMALE ENGINEER AND
ENGINEERING STUDENTS ON BEHALF.
OF MULTIPLE ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF CIVIL
ENGINEERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT. THE STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO WE HAVE
THE GIRL SCOUTS WERE DOING
GRAPHIC JOB OF INTRODUCING
YOUNG WOMEN TO STEM FIELDS.
EARLY ON. STEM ENTERS AND MAKE
BASS PRO. MEMBERS BRING ME
GIVING THE A WARM WELCOME WITH
ROUND OF APPLAUSE. EVERS WHERE
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AC ARE ONE
FIFTY NINE. SO MAKING HER
RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHANT RELATIVE
TO CALIFORNIA THAT THIS WEEK
DOCTOR CHECK EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'M HERE TODAY
PRESENT YOU SEE ARE ONE FIVE
NINE EIGHT ZERO ONE FIVE NINE
WORK THE WEEK OF SEVENTEEN YOUR
FAVORITE TWENTY. TWENTY IS
CALIFORNIA FIT RANKS FORTY
EIGHT THE NATION ADULT OBESITY
COLONEL BCV RATES IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT 26% UP FROM 18% IN 20009%
IN NINETEEN NINETY THE
CALIFORNIA FORM OF EDUCATION
STATE OVER 50% OF CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN ARE NOT PHYSICALLY FIT.
THE CENTER YOU CAN WHEN
PREVENTION AS THE ALMOST TWO
THIRDS OF ALL YOU THE UNITED
STATES TO AT LEAST ONE SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGE A DAY. IS A
POOR. TO YOU. OF IMPROPER
NUTRITION AND ACTIVITY WITH
THAT SAID- I WOULD HUMBLY ASK
THE RIGHT VOTE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR CHANCY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ON THE RESOLUTION
DOCTOR CHEN YOU WOULD LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. YES
PLEASE MYSTERY. FIRST ROLE BE
ABLE FOR CO AUTHORS CAR CLUB OF
THE ROLE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
CO AUTHORS. ON THE RESOLUTION
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SIXTY
SEVEN CO AUTHORS ADDED IN
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE IN PERCENT
HI. I AM SAY NAY YES BUT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. ON SAID
A THIRD READING FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING TO CONSENT CALENDAR.
THEN A MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR. SOMETHING WAS IN ONE
SIXTY FOUR BY SOMEONE AT THE
RUBIO FELL TO DAY. MINUS
PENSION. CLICK BELOW. ALL
MEMBERS THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS THIS PAST
MONDAY. WAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELENDEZ IS BIRTHDAY WHEN YOU
SEE HER IN THE LOUNGE PLEASE
WISH VERY BELATED HAPPY
BIRTHDAY THE SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY FIRST NO FLOOR SESSION A
CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT ONE PM I EIGHT
ORDERING A STRIP OPEN BORROW.
FRIDAY FEB TWENTY FIRST PURPOSE
OF THE- INTRODUCTION THIS IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. AND WE
ARE NOW MOVING TO A GERMAN TO
MEMORY. MEMBERS OUT ASKS THAT
YOU TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR. WE ARE AND ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS WE ARE
DETERMINED TO MEMORY PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS. REPORTER
REMOVE YOUR CONVERSATION FROM
THE GREEN CARPET SO WE MAY
PROCEED.
MEMBERS WE ARE THE
GERMANS IN MEMORY PLEASE TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS RAN PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. MR THEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. TODAY I RISE WITH A
HEAVY HEART TO ASK THIS BODY TO
JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF LOS
ANGELES DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FREDERICK MISS ROPING.
FRED PASSED AWAY ON THE OCTOBER
TWELFTH OF LAST YEAR AFTER
PROLONGED ILLNESS. HE SERVE THE
LOS ANGELES DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE FOR NINETEEN YEARS. TO
MANY OF FRIENDS COLLEAGUES AND
FRIENDS HE WAS A VERY SPECIAL
HUMAN BEING. HE WAS KNOWN FOR
HIS STRONG WORK ETHIC AND
IMPECCABLE PEOPLE SKILLS.
WHEREVER HE WENT FRED SHADED
THE ATMOSPHERE WITH CAMARADERIE
AND PROFESSIONALISM HE KNEW HOW
TO DRAW PEOPLE MOST IMPORTANTLY
HE KNEW HOW TO LISTEN. AS A
TALENTED- FRED HANDLED SOME OF
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICES
MOST COMPLEX CASES INCLUDING
CHILD ABUSE CASES. INVOLVING
HEAD TRAUMA COLD CASE RAPE
TRIALS AND GANG HOMICIDE. AT
THE CONCLUSION OF A CHILD SEX
ABUSE TRIAL FRED AND HANDLED
THE PARENTS OF THE VICTIM
RECOGNIZE HOW SPECIAL FRED WAS
WHEN THEY WROTE IN A LETTER OF
COMMENDATION AFTER MEETING WITH
FRED. AFTER FEET MEETING WITH
MISTER CASTRO BEING THERE WAS
NO DOUBT IN OUR MINDS THANK
HEAVENS CASE WOULD BE
PROSECUTED WITH THE MOST MOST
CARE AND ATTENTION TO DETAIL
RECALL. CONVICT SO WHEN YOU
KEVIN SKATE WILL. OKAY SEX OF
THIS CASE OF MR MISTER OP. IT
FELT AS IT WAS MISTER MISTER OP
WAS ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO US AND
TRANSPARENT IN THIS
COMMUNICATION. IS THE SHIP
TENNIS CITY DEDICATION AND
THOROUGH- NOUS INSTILL
CONFIDENCE IN US. UP THROUGH
THE TRIAL. FRED IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE. A PREEN AND HIS THREE
YOUNG CHILDREN ELENA NINE.
ELIAS SIX AND ALEXANDER FOR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MISTER NAZARIAN MISTER
GALLAGHER YOUR RECOGNIZE FOR
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I ASKED THAT WE
CLOSE AND ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
OF JESS DOUGLAS ROADIE. TAKEN
FROM US TOO YOUNG ON JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY. HE WAS BORN ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIFTH TWO
THOUSAND FIVE AND YUBA CITY
JESS WAS THE SON OF RICK AND
FRITZ HE ROADIE AN OLDER
BROTHER TO LIBYA. AND ALLAH.
FROM A VERY YOUNG AGE. JESS WAS
ACTIVE IN VARIOUS ATHLETICS
INCLUDING SOCCER BASKETBALL
BASEBALL. AND THE CROSS.
HOWEVER THE SUPPORT HE HAD
BECOME MOST PASSIONATE. ABOUT
WAS FOR. LAST FALL AFTER SOME
ENCOURAGEMENT JUST TRIED OUT
FOR HIS SCHOOL FLAG FOOTBALL
TEAM AND HE LOVED IT. AND HE
REALLY BELIEVED THAT HE HAD
FOUND HIS CALLING AND EVEN HAD-
IN THE COACH'S AWARD FOR
OUTSTANDING LEADERSHIP. HE
LOVES VIDEO GAMES- JESS ALSO
ENJOYED WORKING OUT WAS ALWAYS
EAGER. TO TALK ABOUT HIS
PHYSICAL PROGRESS HANGING OUT
WITH FRIENDS PLAYING VIDEO
GAMES SKIING GOLF. AND FLY
FISHING WERE OTHER ACTIVITIES
THAT JESS EITHER ENJOYED
IMMENSELY OR- ASPIRED TO GET
BETTER AT. THOSE AT NEW JETS
WILL NEVER FORGET HIS
CONTAGIOUS LAUGH. AS IS FATHER
RICK SAID AT THE MEMORIAL HE
WAS A CHILL KIDS. HE HAD A
FUNNY QUIRKY SELF DEPRECATING
SENSE OF HUMOR AND LOVE GIVING
A LAUGH JUST AS MUCH AS
RECEIVING GOOD NATURED. TEASING
OFTEN. HAD JUST DOUBLED OVER IN
LAUGHTER. I RECENTLY. HAD
JESS'S CLASS HERE ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND I'VE I
REMEMBER- TAKING A PICTURE HERE
AT THE FRONT AS WE OFTEN DO
WITH THE CLASS AND- TALK AND
JUST DIDN'T YOU DIDN'T TALK A
LOT. HE WAS A MAN OF MANY WORDS
BUT YOU COULD ALWAYS SENSE FROM
HIM A KIND. THEN GENTLE SPIRIT.
ON SO MANY LEVELS THIS WAS A
MAN WHO WAS REALLY COMING INTO
HIS OWN FINDING HIS WAY
ACADEMICALLY AND ATHLETICALLY
WAS PURE JOY TO SEE. HE WAS IT
I BELIEVE- PROUD RECENTLY TO
EARN THE GOLD NON ROLE AT HIS
SCHOOL. YES WILL ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED HE TOUCHED MANY
LIVES IN HIS IN HIS SHORT LIFE
THE- A LOCAL CHURCH GLAD
TIDINGS CHURCH WAS PACKED FULL
OF PEOPLE TO REMEMBER HIM. AND
AGREED TOGETHER WITH HIS FAMILY.
AND SO IT DAY MEMBERS ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
JESS DOUGLAS ROADIE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR GERMANY MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT AND RECOGNITION
AND ASK FOR WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF THE REVENUE GEORGE
WALKER SMITH. GEORGE WALKER
SMITH WAS A TITAN IN SAN DIEGO
CIVIC LIFE FOR OVER SIX DECADES
IN A TRAILBLAZING LEADER IN THE
REGION'S AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. HE DIED THIS PAST
SATURDAY AT THE AGE OF NINETY
ONE AND HE LEAVES A LEGACY THAT
JOB STARTED IN THE POOL PUT AN
EXTENDED INTO PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND POLICY X. IT IS NO SECRET
IN SAN DIEGO THE GEORGE WALKER
SMITH WAS A DEAR FRIEND OF MINE
AND I THE FRIEND OF EVERYONE
WHO WORKED HARD AT THE
COMMUNITY. YEAH FOUND IMPACT ON
MY LIFE. BUT NOT IN FOR THE
SCHOOL BOARD HAD BEEN FOR
GEORGE SMITH WHO CALL A GROUP
OF LEADERS. OF WHEN HE WAS HE
HAD RESIGNED FROM THE BOARD AND
THEN HE HAD OTHERS HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED. AND EVENTUALLY THEY
DECIDED THAT I WOULD RUN AND
DESPITE THE FACT THAT I HAVE TO
ADMIT. OTHERS CALL THE MEETING
INFORMED ME THAT THEY HAD
ALREADY ORGANIZED COMMITTEE IN
THAT I WAS RUNNING FOR THE
SCHOOL BOARD. HE WAS AN EXTREME
POURTANT STORED OF SAN DIEGO'S
COMMUNITY. OF FROM HE CAME FROM
THE PLANTATIONS OF ALABAMA TO
THE SAN DIEGO SCHOOL BOARD. AND
HE HAD A GUIDING PHILOSOPHY
THAT NO ONE SHOULD LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY WITHOUT TRYING TO
MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT BETTER
THAN THE ONE THEY FOUND. IN A
LITTLE THE BILL ALABAMA
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT GEORGE
PARENTS RIDE MINE WERE
SHARECROPPERS THEY DIDN'T HAVE
MONEY TO SEND HIM TO HIGH
SCHOOL AND THERE WAS NO HIGH
SCHOOL FOR BLACKS IN HAINES
BILL AT THAT TIME. AFTER
FINISHING AT THE HEAD OF
ELEMENT CLASS THE WHITE PLANTED
OWNER AFFORDED OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND PRESBYTERIAN HIGH SCHOOL
IN ANOTHER TOWN WHICH ALLOWED
AFRICAN AMERICAN BECOME TO BE A
BIT IN THOSE SCHOOLS. HE TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL AS
VALEDICTORIAN OF THE PRESS OF
THE PRESBYTERIAN SCHOOL. AND HE
YEAH DOLLARS. BUT HE AT THAT.
PLEDGE AND ANOTHER PRESBYTERIAN
SCHOOL GEORGE OFTEN TOLD OF
THE- STORY THAT HE WAS THE ONLY
BAD WHEN HE GOT THE HUNDRED
DOLLARS SCHOLARSHIP HE WROTE A
THANK YOU LETTER TO THE
PRESIDENT THAT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE SCHOOL THAT GAVE HIM A
SCHOLARSHIP. AND THE PRESIDENT
SAID I WAS THE FIRST TIME
ANYONE HAD EVER WRITTEN HIM A
LETTER OF FOR THIS SHIP AND
YOUR DOES HOW BUT EVERY YEAR
HIS TUITION WAS PAID ANY
BELIEVE THIS BECAUSE OF THE
LETTER THAT HE WROTE THANK THE
FOR THE HUNDRED. TURN THE SIGHT
OF. BECAUSE HE WANTED TO BE YOU
ALL HAD DREAMS OF BECOMING A
DOCTOR. SO HE RETURNED TO HIS
HOME IN ALABAMA ONLY TO FIND
THAT THE DOORS OF ALL THE
MEDICAL SCHOOLS HAD BEEN CLOSED
AND LATCHED SHUT. TO AFRICAN
AMERICANS. AFTER LITERALLY
WATCHING THE GRAVE INJUSTICE
AND MURDER OF JIM CROW SOUTH.
GEORGIA DECIDED HE WOULD HE OF
FOLKS WHO WORK AS A REFERENCE
IN IN THE PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH.
HE WENT TO PITTSBURGH HE WAS
ORDAINED AS A MINISTER. AND HE
AND HIS WIFE AFTER HIS HIS
ORDINATION. MOVED TO SAN DIEGO
WHERE THEY STARTED CHRIST
UNITED PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH IN
NINETEEN FIFTIES. THAT TO US
THE GATED COMMUNITY A RACES
COMMUNITY SOME. DID NOT SO
FOLKS OF COLOR. AND RE
REDLINING WAS STRICTLY
ENFORCED. WELL TO ALL WHO HAD
SPECIAL TALENTS. BUT REVENUE
SMITH WAS ONE OF THE BEST
BRIDGE BIT BUILDERS I HAVE EVER
KNOWN. AFTER SERVING AS A
COMMUNITY RELIGIOUS LEADER AND
ON SEVERAL BOARDS HE RAN FOR
OFFICE IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE.
AND BECAME THE FIRST. ELECT SAN
DIEGO. DOOR JOBS THIS BY
BUILDING. A DIVERSE COALITION.
HE MADE IT A POINT TO REACH OUT
TO PEOPLE THAT WERE DIFFERENT
AND HE WAS SO THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS THE LATINOS OF
BLACKS AND WHITES FROM ALL OVER
SAN DIEGO. WORKED WITH JOY AS
AS A MEMBER SCHOOL BOARD. HE
BECAME A FORCE FOR DIVERSITY
AND ACT THE MINUTES A- AND
PRACTICES IN DISTRICT. SERVING
FOR SIXTY YEARS. THE CONTENT
BUT CHAMPION OF EDUCATION.
GEORGE WALKER SMITH WENT ON TO
SERVE AS THE PRESIDENT OF
NATIONAL. ASSOCIATION SEVEN
SIX. TOO MANY STATE AND LOCAL
BOARDS THAT ARE FAR TOO NOT
STILL. BUT THE THINGS GEORGE
SMITH DID TO BE SANDY TO GET.
NONE WAS MORE AND- OR- THAN THE
DEVELOP IN THE FOUNDING OF A
GROUP CALLED THE CATFISH CUB.
THIS STARTED AS A SMALL
GATHERING OF FRIENDS. A MAIL
CARRIER OF FIRE CHIEF AND A
REVEREND. BECAME A AND IT
BECAME A WEEKLY COMMUNITY EVENT
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS. AT
CATFISH CLUB NO MATTER WHAT
YOUR PARTY WAS YOUR COLOR OR
YOUR GENDER. YOU COULD GET UP
AND GIVE YOUR VIEW IN YOUR
PRESENTATION. THESE
RELATIONSHIPS AND COMMUNITY
THAT'S BECAME ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT AFTER THE BEATING OF
RODNEY KING. BY L. BECAUSE
JOINT SMITH BUILT HIS ON. OF
LOVE FRIENDSHIP IN HUMAN
COMPASSION. HE WAS ABLE TO
GUIDE. EVERY MANY COMMUNITIES
TO THE MANY TRIALS OF
YESTERDAY'S GONE BY. WE CAN
ACHIEVE A LITTLE OF WHAT GEORGE
DID WE CAN CONTINUE TO BUILD
UPON THE FOUNDATION OF LOVE
FRIENDSHIP AND HUMAN
COMPASSION. AND INSURE TODAY IS
BETTER YESTERDAY AND BETTER
THAN TOMORROW. GEORGE WALKER
SMITH IS SURVIVED BY HIS
DAUGHTER AND SON IN A NUMBER OF
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. HE IS SORELY
MISSED IN SAN DIEGO HE IS THE
MOST RECOGNIZED. INSIDE GOING
AFTER. I CAN LILLY BUT WELCOME
IS DIEGO AND WE SINCERELY
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE YOU WE
ENJOY IN MEMORY OF. WALKER
SMITH. THANK YOU WEBER YOU
MA'AM PLEASE READ THE NAME OF
THE DEAD TO BE IN THE JOURNAL A
REQUEST TO JOURNAL MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAIN. MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUES SINGING HEARING
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
MR BONTA MOVES AND MISS RIVAS
SEC THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED. UNTIL MONDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY B.
R. TURNED.